[موسيقى]
جزاء الغيم تنهمر الحروف
لها نغم يحس به الشغوف
يرى فيها غصوننا باسقات
على اطرافها تدنو القطوش
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
[موسيقى]
الا ايها السيف الذي ليس مغمدا ولا فيه
مرتاب ولا منه عاصم هنيئا لضرب الهام
والمجد والعلا وراجيك والاسلام انك سالم
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
الرفاده واصلها ان العرب كانوا اذا نزل
بهم الاضياف ترافدوا وتعاونوا على قراهم
فيجلبوا اهل كل بيت مما بحضرته من الطعام
والشراب يقول طرفه ولست بحلال اتلاع مخافه
ولكن متى يسترفد القوم ارفد ويقال للرجل
انه عظيم المرفد اذا جاءه الضيف فرفده بنو
عمه ومنه قيل ناقه رفود وهي التي تملا
الرفد وهو القدح
[موسيقى]
عن سليمان بن يسار انه قال تودد الناس
واستعطافهم نصف الحلم وسئل بعض الحكماء ما
شريطه الصديق قال ان يساعدك في جميع امرك
ويظهر الحسن عنك ويذيعه لك ويستر القبيحه
عليك ويدفعه عنك ويهجنه عندك ويعرفك عيوبك
ويستنزلك برفق منها ويخبرك بمحاسنك ويحثك
على الزياده منها وان يفي لك عند النائبه
ويشركك في المصيبه فاذا فعل ذلك فهو
الصديق الودود
قال بعض الحكماء لا ينبغي لاحد ان يدع
الحزم لظفر ما له عاجز ولا يرغب في
التضييع لنكبه حلت على حازم
[موسيقى]
من طرائف القدماء ان اشعب مره بقرب منزل
احد بخلاء قريته فراى امراه الرجل البخيل
تحضر له لحما فبادر بالدخول مسلما فرد
عليه البخيل السلام فجلس اشعب جلسه الزائر
المتاني فتوضا البخيل صاحب البيت وبادر
مصلاه قائلا اني على نيه صلاه مئه ركعه
يعني يريد ان يفهم اشعب فيغادر فما كان من
اشعب الا ان اضطجع وقال باسمك اللهم وضعت
جنبي
[موسيقى]
قال ابن سعيد الاندلسي في كتابه نشوه
الطرب في تاريخ جاهليه العرب
يحكى ان انو شروان ملك الفرس عاب على بعض
العرب تجوالهم في اقطار الارض وقله سكناهم
في المباني فاجابه الاعرابي الذي كان في
مجلسه ذاك لان ملكنا الارض ولم تملكنا
[موسيقى]
قالت العرب الحرب غشوم لانها تنال غير
الجاني وقالوا في صفتها اولها شكوى
واوسطها نجوى واخرها بلوى وقالوا الحرب
مره المذاق اذا كشفت عن ساق من صبر فيها
عرف ومن ضعف عنها تلف والحرب اول ما تكون
فتيه تسعى بزينتها لكل جهود حتى اذا
استعرت وشب ضرامها عادت عجوزا غير ذات
خليلي
[موسيقى]
يقولون جلس فلان لوحده والصواب ان نقول
جلس وحده بحذف اللام يقول الله تعالى واذا
ذكرت ربك في القران وحده وللو على ادبارهم
نفورا
وقال تعالى وبدا بيننا وبينكم العداوه
والبغضاء ابدا حتى تؤمنوا بالله وحده
يقولون اتبعت القول بالفعل والصواب اتبعت
القول الفعل بحذف الباء لانه ينصب مفعولين
من غير واسطه يقول تعالى ثم ارسلنا رسلنا
تترى كلما جاء امه رسولها كذبوه فاتبعنا
بعضهم بعضا وجعلناهم احاديث فبعدا لقوم لا
يؤمنون
[موسيقى]
يقولون هذا الشيء يخطف البصر فيكسرون
الطاء ويقولون في الماضي خطفا والافصح ان
نقول يخطفوا بفتح الطاء وبه جاء القران
الكريم يكاد البرق يخطف ابصارهم
[موسيقى]
يقولون في المثل الشائع الحديث ذو شجون
فما قصه هذا المثل
السجون هنا جمع شجن بفتح فسكون وهو الشعبه
والطريقه اي ان الحديث ذو شعب وذو طرائق
وهذا المثل لضبه ابن اد وكان له ابنان سعد
وسعيد فخرجا في طلب ابل لهما فرجع سعد ولم
يرجع سعيد فكان ضبه كل ما راى رجلا مقبلا
قال اسعد ام سعيد فذهبت مثلا ثم ان ضبه
بينما هو يسير يوما ومعه الحارث بن كعب
وكان ذلك في الشهر الحرام اذ اتى على مكان
فقال له الحارث اترى هذا الموضع فاني لقيت
فيه فتى هيئته كذا وكذا
فقتلته واخذت منه هذا السيف فاذا بصفه
الرجل الذي ذكره هي صفه سعيد فقال له ضبه
ارني السيف انظر اليه فناوله اياه فعرفه
سيف ولده فقال له الحديث ذو شجون ثم حمل
عليه السيف فضربه به حتى قتله فلامه الناس
في ذلك وقالوا اقتلت في الشهر الحرام فقال
سبق السيف العذل فذهبت مثلا هي الاخرى
[موسيقى]
اضعت لكم سؤالا في تويتر يقول ما بيت
الشعر الذي يملا نفسك هذه الايام
وفيما يلي استعرض معكم بعض ما وصلني من
مشاركاتكم هذه مشاركه من ايه تقول يا من
رحلتم وهذا الود ما رحل لله يعود سئمنا
البعد والامل
ومشاركه من عبد الله محمد يقول ارى
العنقاء تكبر ان تصادى فعاند من تطيق له
عنادا
واسماعيل يقول لعمرك ما ضاقت بلاد باهلها
ولكن اخلاق الرجال تضيق
مشاركه من احمد الائمي في الهوى العذري
معذره لو شفك الوجد لم تعدل ولم تلومي
اخذ شطرا من بيت وشطرا اخر من بيت اخر من
القصيده
نورا احمد تقول
البيت لنزار انا متعب ودفاتري تعبت معي هل
للدفاتر يا ترى اعصاب
ومشاركه من اما تقول لا تلقى ظهرك الا غير
مكترث ما دام يصحب فيه روحك البدن
والبيت للمتنبي طبعا فهد ضيف الله يقول
تهيم الى نوع فلا الشمل جامع ولا الحبل
موصول ولا القلب مقصر والبيت لعمر بن ابي
ربيعه
مشاركه من سلطان يقول لعمرو كم الابصار
تنفع اهلها اذا لم يكن للمبصرين بصائر
ومشاركه من خطاب الجبوري
يقول بيتي الذي قلت فيه احاول كتم الامي
ولكن انين القلب تفضحه الدموع
محمد الحاج حسين ما كنت اهوى الدار الا
باهلها
المفروض انك وضعت واوا في وما كنت اهوى
الدار الا باهلها على الدار بعد الراحلين
سلام
ابراهيم يقول يا ساكنين بقلبي اينما رحلوا
مراحلين بقلبي اينما ساروا غبتم فاظلمت
الدنيا لغيبتكم وضاق من بعدكم رحب واقطار
مشاركات جميله حقيقه البيت الذي تمتلئ به
نفسك هو البيت الذي تردده دائما تشعر
دائما انك تبتهج عندما
ياتي او يعن لك في في بال
طارق يقول اذا ما كنت ذا قلب قنوع فانت
ومالك الدنيا سواء
وصالح الطوقي يقول وابعد ما يرجى العناق
وانما كفانا من الاحلام لمحه عاشقي
ما ابئس العشاق بلال الزيدان يقول صبور
ولو لم تبقى مني بقيه قول ولو ان السيوف
جواب وقور واحداث الزمان تنوشني وللموت
حولي جيئه وذهاب
ومشاركه اخيره من دكتور فيصل يقول وانما
رجل الدنيا وواحدها من لا يعول في الدنيا
على رجلي وهذه من ابيات الطغراء في لاميه
العجم
اشكر لكم هذه المشاركات الجميله وهذا
التفاعل اما انا فتمتلئ نفسي دائما بابيات
المتنبي العظيم الذي ساحدثكم عنه بعد قليل
حديثا ماتعا
[موسيقى]
احدثكم عن شاعر عظيم ربما ابى الله ان
يموت ذكرها اليوم بعد مرور الف سنه واكثر
على وفاته تجد ان مئات الناس بل ربما الاف
الناس يستشهدون بابياته يوميا ويذكرون
اسمه
ويكتبون اسمه واشعاره في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ربما لا تكاد تمر ساعه بدون ان
يذكر هذا الرجل ابى ذكره ان يموت حقا ربما
لانه تحدث عن ضمائر الناس ربما لان الحكمه
كثرت في اشعاره ربما لان كلامه في كلام
الشعراء كان ككلام الانبياء في كلام البشر
اسباب كثيره
جعلت ذكرها هذا الرجل يبقى حيا حتى بعد
الف سنه من وفاته
انه المتنبي المتنبي صاحب المطالع القويه
صاحب الاشعار التي تمتلئ بالحكمه
اعلى الممالك ما يبنى على الاساليب كفى
بكذاء ان ترى الموت شافيا اود من الايام
ما لا توجه
وكثير من الاشعار
اضف الى ذلك الصور السرياليه العجيبه
المتنبي
الى جانب كل ما ذكرت كان رجلا شجاعا وهذه
حقيقه شهد له بها الاعداء قبل الاصدقاء
كان يصحب سيف الدوله الحمداني في حملاته
على بلاد الروم وقد وصف تلك الحملات وصفا
دقيقا يقول في مطلع قصيده الراي قبل شجاعه
الشجعان هو اول وهي المحل الثاني فاذا هم
اجتمعا لنفس حره بلغت من العلياء كل مكان
ويرسم المتنبي في هذه القصيده صوره معقده
ولكنها مدهشه يصف جند سيف الدوله وهم
يعبرون نهرا ارسنال وهو من روافد الفرات
ويقع اليوم في تركيا ويسمونه نهر مراد
الغبار كثيف يستر العيون فالخيول لا ترى
بعيونها بل باذانها يقول في جحفل سترى
العيون غباره فكانما يبصرن بالاذان
وعبرت الخيول نهر ارسنال سباحه وبلغ الماء
عماءم الفرسان فنشر هذه العمائم على سطح
النهر يقول حتى عبرنا بارسنا سوابحا ينشرن
فيه عمائم الفرسان ثم تاتي الصوره المدهشه
مياه النهر تفصل بين غبار الضفه اليمنى
وغبار الضفه اليسرى يتفرق الغباران عند
الماء ثم يلتقيان في الاعالي
يقول والماء بين عجاجتين مخلص تتفرقان به
وتلتقيان قالوا لابي الطيب ما هكذا يثور
الغبار في الشتاء والقصيده تصف غزوه شتويه
فقال انما وصفت ما عاينت وتمضي القصيده
ولا بد فيها من حكم المتنبي وما اكثرها ان
السيوف مع الذين قلوبهم كقلوبهن اذا التقى
الجمعان تلقى الحسام على جراءه حده مثل
الجبان بكف كل جبان ثم ياتي الى الممدوح
يمدح سيف الدوله يا من يقتل من اراد بسيفه
اصبحت من قتلاك بالاحسان فاذا رايتك حار
دونك ناظري واذا مدحتك حار فيك لساني
وفي هذين البيتين الاخيرين لو تعلمون من
ظروب البلاغه
وحسن التقسيم والتعليل
كان المتنبي يتجرا على سيف الدوله بالعتاب
يا اعدل الناس الا في معاملتي فيك الخصام
وانت الخصم والحكم سيعلم الجمع ممن ضم
مجلسنا بانني خير من تسعى به قدم انا الذي
نظر الاعمى الى ادبي واسمعت كلماتي من به
صمم
ومن الجراه في ذلك الزمن وفي كل زمن ان
يمدح الشاعر نفسه في حضره الامير كان
المتنبي لا ينسى نفسه في كل قصيده ثم هجر
المتنبي حلب واميرها والتحق بامير مصر
كافور ومدحه بقصائد كبيره حتى وان لم يكن
له الحب والاحترام كان طامعا ولكنه ضل
شاعرا
وطوحت الدنيا بالمتنبي فوجد نفسه في بلاد
فارس التي لا يعرف لغه اهلها فقال واوجز
ولكن الفتى العربي فيها غريب الوجه واليد
واللسان
كان المتنبي في كل حالاته شاعرا كبيرا كان
شاعرا وهو غاضب وكان شاعرا وهو صادق وكان
اشعر ما يكون وهو يصف غربته وغربه روحه يا
صاحبي يا خمر في كؤوسكما ام في كؤوسكما هم
وتسهيد الصخره انا مالي لا تحركني هذه
المدام ولا هذه الاباريد
اليوم بعد اكثر من الف سنه على وفاته بقي
المتنبيان للدنيا وشاغلا للناس انام ملء
جفوني عن شواردها ويسهر الخلق جراها
ويختصموا ولقد صدق حين قال ودع كل صوت غير
صوتي فانني انا الطائر المحكي والاخر
الصدى
[موسيقى]
يقول لك الزمان بكل وجه حياه الدمع مراه
الكمال حياه الدمع اكرم من طريق محوث
بالتكبر والتعالي وتذكر من قديم الشعر
بيتا جبته اليك اخيله الرحال نصيبك في
حياتك من حبيب نصيبك في منامك من خيالي
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]